we're going to begin with former
president trump's growing legal problems
and the furious response and furious is
a word from him and his supporters now
sources tell cbs news that trump's
allies are preparing for quote political
warfare against his opponents in
congress and law enforcement ahead of
the midterm elections the former
president was questioned under oath in a
new york civil case yesterday and he
asserted his legal right not to answer
many many many times now this follows
monday's fbi search of his mar-a-lago
home robert costa has the latest on the
president's legal drama
how do you feel mr trump how do you feel
former president trump wednesday invoked
the fifth during a four-hour videotape
deposition in a new york state
investigation into his business
practices
new york state attorney general leticia
james's office wrote that james will
pursue the facts and the law wherever
they may lead trump insisted he had no
choice but to decline to answer
questions and that he did nothing wrong
but taking the fifth is something he has
previously criticized
if you're innocent why are you taking
the fifth amendment cbs news legal
analyst ricky clemen says trump's
decision was understandable any lawyer
with his or her assault would have told
donald trump that it was essential for
him to invoke his fifth amendment
still trump faces other ongoing
investigations criminal probe led by the
manhattan district attorney into his
businesses there and a fulton county
georgia district attorney on his efforts
to overturn the state's 2020 election
results meanwhile trump and gop allies
continue to lash out at the fbi over its
search of his florida home earlier this
week look this is this is the doj run
amok pennsylvania congressman scott
perry spoke out last night about the fbi
seizing his cell phone tuesday his
lawyer says he is not the target of the
probe now the president's house was
raided monday do you think they're
linked
right
i do think i think all of this is linked
trump appointed fbi director christopher
wray declined to comment on the trump
search but had this to say about the
recent rise of threats against the
justice department again violence
against law enforcement
is not the answer no matter what anybody
is upset about
the florida judge who signed off on the
fbi warrant has been facing a wave of
violent threats on right-wing social
media where users have published his
personal information and threatened his
family
boy bob what a time to be alive there's
so much chatter on the streets about
everything but what do you think all
these mounting what do you think all
this means for the president's mounting
legal troubles and his potential to run
for 2024 he certainly is doing a lot of
teasing that he's leaning in that
direction the chatter publicly in the
republican party gail is that they're
all rallying around the former
president's side they're excited
in the sense that they can have
political warfare against the fbi and
the justice department but privately
based on my reporting it's a different
picture this is a republican party that
knows the former president in many ways
is damaged because of these
investigations because of what happened
on january 6 and a lot of them privately
feel like mitch mcconnell the senate
republican leader wait and see we don't
know the full scope of evidence here and
where this is exactly going to lead i
think both sides need to wait and see
don't you bob everybody's speculating
everybody's drawing conclusions when we
really don't know what they have true
that's right i mean so many people right
now are making conclusions not knowing
exactly what the fbi has in terms of
archival materials they've taken from
mar-a-lago and what the goj's grand jury
is doing on so many other fronts i have
a motto as a reporter assume nothing we
don't know where this goes yeah although
it was pretty remarkable when uh senator
tim scott was sitting right where you
are and he made that same point he was
beat up pretty badly in conservative
media and by some other his colleagues
in congress bob great to see you thank
you great to see you in person yeah
indeed